[Music]
not enough fish news why who said what
who have submitted by Carla I like fish
women successfully sued a dating agency
over a lack of suitors lack of so this
is Isaac's not enough fish in the sea no
this is like that one that all the dudes
were doing and they were getting all
BOTS replying to oh like the [ __ ]
sugar daddy the one for guys remember
they all got busted because the database
got leaked it was just guys talking to
each other basically so funny
there were some girls ladies that got on
and then they're cheating I heard there
was like 0.3 percent actually views on
them oh also for the ladies I want to
cheat I feel like it's easier if a woman
wants to cheat usually a woman will
cheat for her emotional needs not being
met and so they'll like find a guy that
meets their emotional needs and cheat
like in real life like I think it's
easier for women to find that oh no [ __ ]
and then guys are like I need a service
to find sex basically I forgot the
specific stats but in social psych they
are saying like how young marriages or
whatever or like during the 20s or like
to forties range there's more single
males but then from 40 and above like
there's more single it makes sense cuz
they're probably bunch of divorces yeah
single females yeah hey but they new
here 70 40 is not so bad for home wait
for which one yeah for both I guess for
7-year old dudes odd sure but why would
the 40 year old wanna be with a 70 year
old no no he it wasn't wonder this any
old woman she's 70 huh guy who's married
to a 7 year old wife wants a 40 year old
girl
the logic is that he want the Yonkers no
matter what yeah younger than 72 you
yeah you want Beyonce and also taste
what it's like to be on I see girls
don't mind older dude so he'll leave the
new girl for it
house isn't Casey older than you right
less than two years do you like older
dudes geriatric chaser I like older
dudes I like younger dudes
Gio's a cougar yeah and I'm more mature
so up Stalder totally very true very
true that's why everyone Cece was the
guy borrowing Gio's baby yeah cuz you're
so mature yeah all right so this story
is about two he's stopped borrowing with
baby wounded so Theresa is a 47 year old
mother of three in the UK and she
approached this dating website called
70/30 back in 2013 for her requirements
she wanted a sophisticated gentleman
ideally employed in the finance industry
he should lead a wealthy lifestyle and
be open to travel internationally and
the most important requirement for her
was his willingness to have more
children because she wants to have four
kids that's kind of cool after three
kids and you're single and you're taking
care of three kids and you still want
another one at 47 yeah that's crazy
scripts of joy from it I guess so then
she ended up signing up to the service
and paying twelve thousand six hundred
British pounds which is about sixteen
thousand US dollars six dollars to find
a dude yeah and so she sued them for
deceit and misrepresentation because she
eventually found out that there were
only about 100 active male members all
together so there's no way like her
requirements would have been met since
they're so specific yes a really
expensive service yeah but it's kind of
good too because then you feel like
you're gonna get quality exactly she got
conned
she felt that that's what she wanted to
pay more exclusive membership and they
kept matching her up with guys take a
postal worker or some [ __ ] well I don't
know they didn't go into details the
delivery man I like how she goes
specifically I want guys in the finance
and history yeah of course maybe you
know they make the most money of course
stable that industry is not going away I
hope not she's also also she just might
like
know that industry a little bit better
and she's comfortable with this I'll
shoot you
47 what does she look like oh she's
pretty
oh wow yeah is funny when people don't
know her like social status or like were
they worth what they should get like if
she's 47 and she looks [ __ ] horrible
and then she has three [ __ ] up Walmart
looking kids seriously dude you don't
know you're like like seriously you
thought you could get away with this for
15 grams like you better pay 75 like you
want a guy to just sweep you off your
feet and pay for all this [ __ ] and give
you an extra kid you know your level
dude but then for her I'm like yeah I
could see that yeah you could work out
for what think about guys in the
financial district or industry these
cats can pull in all kind of fine honey
honey's but maybe they already pulled
all the fun hunting's that they wanted
to another like look I want some
stability
yeah totally that sounds like man yeah
oh then why are you married you don't
want stability no no I'm talking about
those guys he even said those guys are
not like I said that when he was younger
he used to get mad because he wanted to
have a wife already yeah and like the
family and stuff that's the kind of guy
Steve is also something oh but those all
those guys are not we know those
comedian guys they're all like that
those stereotypes so true second of all
actually industry guys it's like wolf of
Wall Street Cher right you're
stereotyping them no I know but but I'm
not saying it's all of them but it's
highly likely that who she's looking for
because she's trying to find a match of
like a type of guy yeah but what I'm
that type of guy is not looking for that
a comedian a funny well they didn't have
to be commuted they just want it had to
be funny and I wanted them to love me
back and want to want a stable
relationship and that's why you're not
with the Wall Street guy see but I mean
that that pool of people is that's hard
so hard to find if I was a woman and if
I wanted a Wall Street guy it's because
I want someone who would just pay for my
[ __ ] and never be home and [ __ ] me
once in a great while yeah because he's
too busy cooking dinner and he's busy
just making money all the time he won't
give you a kid
yeah but I know that whatever I want
things are gonna be bought and I don't
have to [ __ ] see it maybe financial
guy is code for mob boss no no cuz those
guys you know they have a lot more time
she wants a kid with the guy think about
like that shit's for kids actually yeah
what if he dies
my wife's give kids but they don't like
they're not there for those need to be
as sexy as mob wife here's the thing I
was a kid at all it's cuz it's insurance
policy what no cuz then you got him on
the hook oh she is a businesswoman
herself she's a businesswoman what does
that even mean though
yeah what does that mean she eats
funding for her flower shop oh she did
she pull a ship man right Joe started
painting her as like a money hungry
person no she's not money hungry she was
just want someone that can keep up with
her level no I paid her as a money
present her I painted myself as a money
hungry person I said if I wanted a Wall
Street guy these are the reasons why I'm
really you did say that
well you don't put financial I want
someone in the financial district if
you're not looking for money give me a
freakin ham she also said that you
should lead a wealthy lifestyle right
yeah if if I if I didn't care about that
and I want to look I wouldn't be like
I'm looking for an oil tycoon someone
who's very rich and loves to spend my
money on [ __ ] Range Rovers all day
what's cool about her those luxury car
did put a fleet of Range Rovers for
somebody's now speaking of the Persian
like oil millionaires that like go
through the desert with 50 Range Rovers
you she didn't say she's cool with guys
who get payday loans okay what'd you say
huh saying that she did put her money
where her mouth is and she paid for the
service where a lot of these girls they
can just bag one of these dudes without
even doing that yeah so I feel like she
might not be that money hungry or maybe
she just wants hooked up with a
matchmaker yeah like it's not it's not
like a sugar daddy situation but it's
like older people that are in the same
kind of my business but like levels yeah
you know like she's a business owner
he's a business owner I want to meet
people that aren't fakers like the
celebrity matchmaking yeah but this is
like business matchmakers by the way did
you tell me that your ex is on that
no oh it's gonna be a good jakey news
episode me the [ __ ]
it's not famous though that's but she
has a way of like getting into the
celebrity stuff the one right before who
cares that's funny is this funny because
she's not a celebrity found on there and
it was Nikki that found her on there
yeah clearly like paid to be so that's a
site where celebrities want to hook up
with other celebrities yeah how does
that work yeah yeah it's just so for
privacy purposes so that like
celebrities aren't on bumble you know
just regular it's like you could [ __ ]
Joey Fatone or something yeah but it's
endure weather are they trying to look
for sex are they trying to look for
relation relationships like dating is a
dating Dave coulier's on there but for
celebrities like you have to have a
certain celebrity status from full house
yeah yeah yeah Dave coulier's on their
celebrity status so that so that you're
not with just a bunch of normies I'll be
great too if you're like a c-lister and
you've been irrelevant and then you want
to boost your career back up then you
get with someone that you normally
wouldn't go they have actual like
there's agencies that have books of like
okay this person's looking to boost
their program you're gonna date somebody
yeah and then here's this girl you have
to be cool with him sucking dick and he
getting butt-fucked wallet on one of our
friends got that book presented to him
like yeah we can set up a relationship
with any of these people they're all
looking to boost their program yeah I
saw this thing on Twitter it was like 12
celebrities you would never think being
the [ __ ] relationship together with
and it was like Captain Kirk ins and
[ __ ] like I don't know demi lovato or
some [ __ ] oh it was it was like a crazy
mixer and Demi Lovato no no I just made
that one not know it's that weird though
I was the weird one was Katie Holmes and
Jimmie Foxx
that was a weird one too I was free that
was weird for you Jamie because because
they he started with Tom Cruise and
collateral right oh that's you is
my friend yeah they're way different
realms of this like he seems like more
on the low down low I don't know she
just seemed too much she's in the black
men G who's ever Sam no it's like she
seems I shouldn't even know who black
people are I picture her Dawson's Creek
like those type of people yeah yeah and
then Jamie Foxx is like a whole
different level yeah like he's Lively
he's like funny he seems he's one of the
best entertainers of all time he's won
Oscars yeah but that did good though
that's all that's all that's why that
happened huh what do you Jamie Foxx do
yeah it was sparked news when the dicks
good it breaks [ __ ] barriers it's
true oh I see what you're saying that's
probably the first time Katie Holmes had
sex with a man in years when she got
with Jamie Foxx cuz we know Tom wasn't
in there
[Music]